Haley, Rebecca, just sent a message.
on the chat.
What's that?
Rebecca, just send a message on the chat on this chat.
Okay.
Yeah.
So.
This is concerning. Where's it feels like there's some animosity in both the response that Ken shared and response here. Do you have any idea where coming from?
Just.
Mhm.
No.
Yeah, it would this this initially this QVR has been rescheduled.
By Natalie, and then since or not.
She's not here. I can't reach Justin. I don't know who will be taking in, taking care of this.
I'm gonna be here in a minute; she just texted.
Yeah.
I...
I have another call in 30 minutes that I have to join, but...
Mhm.
But I do want to check in with Ken. Did you message Ken back?
Yeah, I responded to him.
Okay.
Okay, I think we do need Natalie.
Well, it would benefit to have Natalie.
Mmh.
No, no, no, no, no, no, Natalie, no, no, no. Can you tell?
This is.
Natalie.
No, no.
Did you try Natalie before canceling or just Justin?
Justin, because I know Natalie is out on a conference.
Yeah, it seems like...
She says she told them she'd be on, but I don't know who them is.
Yeah, Ken, she did a rescheduled this initially.
Did you CC myself and or Natalie in their email communication?
Yeah.
Yeah, Natalie is there on the email.
Mm.
But I'm not okay.
Not, yeah, sorry.
That's okay, I just...
I added Justin on the email.
PH.
You're saying also Justin was joining too.
Yeah, Justin is offline. I tried reaching out to him.
He said on the status is he, it's he's on a vacation leave.
There.
Anyone else later?
It can respond yet or not.
I.
And did you tell him?
Play the song.
And did you tell him that?
Oh, oh.
I would be joining, Kam.
Yes. Yeah, I did.
Okay.
TA.
Is.
Yeah.
I forward you the email I sent.
I see.
Exactly.
I'm just not sure what he meant by...
A lot of having turned over recently.
turnover because of the new team lead.
My concerns about our team having turned over recently announced.
Oh.
I mean, she's saying they both were going to be on, but like, where's Justin? Still 9 minutes after.
Yes.
She's saying, Natalie feels we're making assumptions, but I don't think it's unfair to make the assumption that somebody who's at a conference and somebody whose teams is on vacation are not, are both not.
This is.
Exactly.
like without them explicitly saying. So I'll speak with her and get this sorted long term.
Okay.
For the short term, I want to message Ken.
Seven.
Yeah, I don't know, man. I...
I don't know.
Think of your ****.
Yeah.
Mhm.
But.
I think it was Sean.
That deals with Ken in the past.
The CX side.
You are on mute, by the way.
What was it you just said?
Hey, Natalie, I thought you were running to the booth.
Ohh, it's just I was going to, but then Lee was saying that he was trying to get Ken to join, so I was gonna...
Yeah, I think if we can join, I mean, I've got a call with Milner in 15 minutes, but if we can get Ken to join, which I know Andy just tried to do, I want to, I'm very interested in the wording advised on concerns about our team having turned over recently.
Yeah.
I wanna know.
I feel like I know what it's about. Maybe it's because of the new team lead that was introduced before Brian left. They were handed over to Rodge and then Rodge is MIA, but then we haven't had any missed monthly business review with them because this is the next one since Brian left.
Yeah.
The.
So I think it's all about the leadership.
Yeah.
But I guess the feeling performance issues from that.
Mhm.
It probably, yeah, it probably isn't. It probably honestly is just the management of the account overall that they're talking about, I bet, because they only have that one engineer, right, Andy?
Yeah.
Yeah, only one. Only one.
which is, they're kind of, they've always been a little grumpy to begin with. Yeah, like he's already like, he's one of those, he's like a Lisa where like, I try to, we did get him like to look at AI and stuff like that, but he's one of those like when you're talking to him, you know.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, Ken is, yeah.
Oh.
Hey, or it's recording, so hopefully this doesn't send over to, but yeah.
To know.
So they don't have access.
He's talking about needing to talk to senior management as soon as possible to explain what is happening with ITBD and management of our account. So it does sound like it's about management and I get the confusion. I, yeah, Natalie, apologies. She asked me if we should reschedule and I said yes.
Yeah.
But it said yes based on.
Yeah, no, that's and that's my bad because I didn't accept the invite. I do that all the time and I need to get better at just like accepting invites, even though I get overwhelmed by all of my tentative meetings at the same time.
We're what we're talking about at like.
I'm like, I know, I know she was aware of it, but I don't know if she's paying for it, and I know she's at a conference.
I know, because I was like, I asked Lee yesterday, he should have known, he should have known I was gonna be on it.
I know, I know Justin's on vacation, according to his teams, and I know that.
Mhm.
Yeah, no, no, no, I see the outline that the all the data was pointing to, I don't think we're gonna have a CX on this call, so I understand what the data was showing, because I even pinged Justin yesterday and I was like, I was like, hey, we are, I talked to Lee, like we are gonna have a deck and stuff for.
Bye.
Oops.
Yeah!
Sound like a Mae.
Ashish.
For MCG, and he was like, "All right, I'm on VL, but I'll join anyways," but who knows? He said that, and he may not have even joined, but yeah, I did plan on joining, but yeah, let's let's just loop Ankur into it. Let's Ankur, so so it's not any any of us, and then...
Did you tell him not to, because he's not?
Yeah.
Yes.
I just, yeah, so I just responded to, you can do you want me to just forward it to Ankur and keep everybody in it?
Yeah, do you want or do we want to just loop loop Ankur in to schedule a call?
You.
I was going to say, you looped me in, you forwarded it to me. Why don't I just take that opportunity to say, hey, Ken, understood that you have that you have concerns. We want to we want to follow up. I'll loop Ankur into that as well.
Yeah.
Okay, yeah, and then if you or Ankur or somebody, if I can get their elder line as well, because I don't know if they're mad at me too, so if they want to talk ****, they can.
Sure.
But.
Yeah.
Just, it just, yeah, I'm looking, I'm looking at it, I'm like, I'm like, I have no indication of what's going on with this with this meeting. We got to get better about the deck creation to do it. I know, Andy, that I'm not, that's not a finger point, right? That's not. I know that you're, you've got resource constraints. We've got to figure out.
Nancy.
of you how to get around that because it's just a challenge the deck.
Mhm.
I was messing with Claude a little bit for the focus technology QBR I'm working on, so I was messing with Claude a little bit. The only thing with Claude, it takes so long to ******* process everything. It's always just thinking and thinking, thinking and working and working and working and coding.
Rebecca just...
Yeah, it doesn't.
Because I...
It, it, well, it is in it, writing it down.
Rebecca, yeah, Rebecca just said an email.
Andrea, Joe, and I already moved to other tasks, so we need to reschedule everything. At this point, I am not even clear on who's handling our account and working with Jacob day-to-day now that Brian and Jerome are gone. We were working with someone named Rodge, but he is not on this email. Was he replaced as well? Consistency and proactive communication are very important to us, so we need to see a vast improvement.
Mm.
send over a few options for us to meet and we will see what works for us, Rebecca. But yeah, I feel like it's the same. Yeah.
Okay, well then it sounds like you and we can all probably go on that call then.
OK, so then.
Mhm.
Yes, Andy, in that case, since she responded to you, please reply back, looping in me and Ankur, like actively. And that way she sees the connectivity and it's not me responding to a thread I wasn't in, which is always a little weird anyway. But yeah.
Sure.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Yeah, I was meeting to actually inform them about moving out of Rodge today, but hey, they beat me to it.
Well, they're gonna love that, right?
Oh my god, I don't have anybody to replace.
Then you'd be like, oh, it was actually a talking point today. I promise we were trying to be somewhat correct.
Singh.
But here's, here's.
Here, here, so, so look here, here's the long and short of it. There was there was internal communication mishap that that caused the request for reschedule. We apologize, that kind of stuff happens. That's got nothing to do with the actual management of the account, right? It's got nothing to do.
Yeah.
Oh.
Mhm.
with the day-to-day communications, with the week-to-week communications, it's a QBR.
So we can bite the bullet on that. So yeah, that was on us.
Uh-huh.
As far as the day to day, week to week, let's just set time to talk before, like see what times are available and Ankur, myself, Natalie, we can all carve time and you as appropriate. We can explain, right? There had been some change as a temporary measure. The goal was to...
Mhm.
Rodge, but we've already brought a full-time replacement, and that's Justin, and that's going to be the solid mechanism to use going, you know, not mechanism, you know what I mean, solid person going forward, and that way we're positioned.
Uh-huh.
to give them reassurance that this is recognized by us as well. Right?
Should I address some of her points about Rodge because he was asking if he's still on the account? And then...
So, just say, say, so state that, so say, say that we we will be transitioning to, I don't know, should we say that Roger still, Roger's still with us and he's still here and he still says say that Rodge is still here and he's still working with the engineer, but we will be.
Rodge will be moving into just put like a more senior position or something like that so that he will he won't then we're going to be replacing with whoever and say that you are going to discuss this on on the call today. Because is anybody actually working with the engineer right now? I just don't want to get caught in a lie either.
Yeah.
if they ask the engineer, because I know sometimes, you know, they talk to the engineers and I don't want them to be like, oh, who's?
And the, the, the, well, Rodge is still checking in with the engineer from time to time also, so.
Okay. Okay, so he does still have those check-in points. So you can say that right now, Rodge is still over the account, but he is being transitioned into another role at ITBD. And then say that we were going to go over this today and I was going to introduce you, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Um...
I would have introduced you to myself because I don't have a team.
Yeah.
PH.
Ohh, man, OK.
And sorry, clients are clients.
All right, I'm going to go meet back up with Vikram, but yeah, let's just get a call scheduled with them. We'll just reassure them too, like, yeah, we have had a lot of changes in the Philippines recently with management, but they're all good changes, right? We're moving in the right direction.
No.
Okay.
Okay, see you guys soon. Thanks. Good morning.
First year.
Hey.
Bye.
Happy Tuesday. Oh, by the way, what's your available date? He's asking for an option for the dates.
I hear.
Yeah, Tuesday.
Kip.
Are you talking to all of us?
Yu.
Yeah, all of us. Well, should I be there? I mean...
I can be.
I think it, I think what I think it might be okay if you come in as like the, because have you actually talked with them that much or just kind of, yeah.
I talked to Ketan. Yeah, I talked to Ketan, but not with Rebecca.
Then, yes.
Because you've got an established rapport with the highest, he's the highest person in the organization. Yeah, but then.
OK.
Yeah.
Yeah, CEO, yeah.
Yeah, so just get on, fall and sword, be like, hey, I know it's, I'm trying to move people around, you know, I'm getting to know the lay of the land. So I do appreciate this partnership and I promise I'm going to get it in the right direction. So just, you know, do something like that.
Yep.
All that, all that fun stuff.
This.
All, all those great things.
Tap tap to answer that. Alright, I have my next call, but yeah, look at.
What?
Options for options for the dates, please. You guys are available.
Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, schedule me any, you can schedule it Wednesday.
Hi.
I'm out Thursday, Friday, but...
Thank you.
Okay, if you guys want, yeah, if you guys want to try to schedule something tomorrow.
Tomorrow, at tomorrow.
To.
Eleven.
Oh.
Tomorrow, 1:30 P.m. Eastern, or...
Yeah, I can do that.
Yeah, let's do 130. That works for me.
Yeah, see if he's got 130 or otherwise I'd have to do like 330 to 5 somewhere in there.
Okay.
Okay, 330 would work for me too. I have a connect with Sarbjeet, but I can move that. So do.
130 and 330. Sure, we'll do that.
Kour.
Yeah.
Alright, thank you so much.
Cool. Thanks, guys. Sorry, sorry. I think it's my fault. I'm sorry. Bye. Remote workers, remote, remote life.
Thank you. Bye.
Bye.
It's it was just, we were all confused.
You know, so...
Up.